hi two quick remarks first there's some
good on my face throughout this video
that's from my kid I'm sorry and
secondly just to be totally clear this
video is about giraffe mating okay I
think we can start good morning Hank
it's Tuesday so yesterday someone
tweeted to us you to do great work have
helped many but sometimes I miss the
days when you just made videos about
giraffe sex fair enough so let's just
recap the basics of giraffe sexuality
the majority of giraffe sex according to
one study up to 90 percent occurs
between two males there's also
occasional same-sex mounting between
female giraffe so heterosexual giraffe
sex is not really the dominant form of
giraffe sexuality but it is how the
babies get made now giraffes can mate
for procreation year-round but they tend
to do it during the rainy season when
food is less scarce because they're less
stressed out and also because plentiful
food makes the prospect of a giraffe
pregnancy slightly less terrifying so
here's how it goes down first a male
giraffe uses his head to poke a female
giraffe in the butt this sometimes
causes the female giraffe to pee as you
can see here and then the male giraffe
will smell and/or taste that peed to
determine if the female is fertile which
she is about four days out of every two
weeks if the pee tastes right and
everybody is on board the male will
stand behind the female for a while
until it's time for the magic to happen
the magic being a period of intercourse
lasting less than two seconds this
extremely brief encounter is followed by
more than a year of pregnancy at the end
of which female giraffes usually produce
a single calf often born six feet tall
and weighing over 150 pounds
needless to say Hank this is an
inefficient process I mean first you've
got to get a male giraffe to sexual
maturity which takes at least seven
years then you gotta have enough food
for the dress not to be stressed out and
then you got to have the right tasting
kind of pee and then you got to be
pregnant for 400 days and then you
usually just get one baby I'll be at a
gigantic and adorable baby and even
after that your baby is very vulnerable
to predators because it's so small and
bad at running but you can't like pick
it up and put it in your pouch and hop
away because you're not a marsupial all
of this means that when giraffe
populations go down it's really hard for
them to recover and they are going down
in fact a new report says the giraffe
populations have fallen by around 40%
since the 1980s there are not only about
98,000 giraffes in the world and they've
just been moved to threatened status by
the International Union for the
Conservation of Nature the cause of the
giraffes decline is of course humans
mostly through habitat destruction
and hunting so it can be really hard to
fathom just how thoroughly humans have
reshaped the planet in the last few
hundred years but here's a bit of
context the total combined weight of
living humans right now is around 300
million tonnes the total combined weight
of our livestock from sheep to chickens
to cows is around 700 million tonnes and
the total combined weight of every
non-human non-domesticated large animal
on earth every penguin and elephant and
shark every whale and giraffe and lion
all of them combined is less than 100
million tonnes when geologists talk
about the Anthropocene the geologic age
of humans radically reshaping the planet
that's part of what they're talking
about the Earth's bacteria by the way
have a combined biomass north of 350
billion tons but I digress right so I
think giraffes have a reasonably good
chance of surviving the Anthropocene
despite their inefficient mating and
that's not because their necks allow
them to reach food other animals can't
reach or because their kicks can
literally kill a lion it's because
humans like them we want them in the
world or at least I hope we do and it
really is our choice if we lose the
draft forever there will only be one
reason why humans since the Columbian
Exchange began a little over 500 years
ago thousands of species have gone
extinct and almost all of those
extinctions are directly attributable to
us we decide we are deciding right now
with the biodiversity of our planet is
going to look like naught for the next
100 or 1,000 years but for many millions
of years and maybe if we can accept that
responsibility we'll begin to take it
more seriously Hank I'll see you on
Friday